c'est beau d'être un beau lieu surtout
quand des joueuses de l'équipe de france
de rugby à 15 viennent à votre rencontre
c'est impressionnant quand même parce
que ça on les voit à la télé filao
leverage que séparés pauline bourdeau
reconnu parmi les cinq meilleures
joueuses du monde et céline ferrer
toutes deux à l'aise bayonne se sont
volontiers prêtés un échange avec les
jeunes filles de l'option rugby c'est
important voilà de leur montrer que non
si on est passé par là pour la plupart
et que le haut niveau et est faisable je
vous continuez à ajustement poussé ces
jeunes filles à avenir très jeune très
jeune au rugby et que
et que peut-être un jour elle touche
croix elle touche front du bout des
doigts aussi l'équipe de france donc
c'est très positif pour le rugby féminin
mais il faut surtout continuer à faire
des résultats pour encourager ces jeunes
filles à à venir l'option rugby du
collège beaulieu a débuté il ya quatre
ans de la 6e à la 3e trente trois
adolescentes pratique aujourd'hui ce
sport une fois par semaine avec un
objectif le championnat de france unss
ce que j'aime dans la bible c'est pareil
que les à celle hestrud équipe on a
commencé ensemble toutes les deux puis
on a vu grandir l'équipe alors c'est
c'est bien on a quelques quelques élèves
du collège beaulieu qui sont maintenant
dans l'équipe dans les équipes de joué
les tours qui sont assidus et très
performante on en a on a même certaines
qui ont incorporé le des pôles espoirs
c'est au collège que se découvrent des
passions comme le rugby féminin qui
aujourd'hui fait école plus de 100
jeunes filles sont inscrites dans les
équipes de l'ue est joué rugby féminin